stopping play there's guano  this is not as their cave  his charity the crowd started to chant  Martin  this is unusual right this is a  something we haven't seen in the law  ever how about ever  where are the pest control the where's  pest control would you need them there  oh they're all over now Gasol with his  towel ready and oh I'm not foolish  enough to try to grab one mine and  describe in detail there's the rabies  shots and they he said they were not fun  so I'm gonna listen to what he has to  say for sure and there's no one out here  this might be the first game delay due  to bat in the history of the NBA or  professional sports and if the  cooperative